The drinking bird has just one degree of freedom. It can rotate around its
pivot point. However, the motion along this axis is fairly complex, and is
difficult to capture in a few simple equations. One brute force method to
create animations is called motion capture. The idea is to capture the
movements of a person or object by using a few strategically placed cameras.
The information recorded is processed to derive the paths of various parts of
the body. These motions are then applied to the model in the virtual world. To
more easily track where each part of the body goes, it's common to attach ping
pong balls or lights to a person while filming them. These attached objects are
called markers. There's a a move toward marker less systems where no special
suits are needed. In the foreground here, you can see the actors pose being
capture and applied to a character. In this clip there's a lot going on. You
might want to watch it a few times. In the upper right the 2 actresses are
being recorded. The cameraman is also moving around the scene. In the lower
right you can see a reconstruction of the actresses's motions. On the left,
these motions are being applied to the 2 computer animation characters in real
time. There're 2 views here on the left. On the one half is the cameraman's
view. The other half shows a fixed camera view of the whole scene. Motion
capture is used extensively in the film and games industry, as it's a
straightforward way to quickly generate animations and is cost-effective. There
are some drawbacks. The first is cost of entry. This process is currently not
something you can easily do without some investment. That said, costs are
coming down, and inexpensive hardware such as Microsoft's Kinect can be used
for capture. You can also use more limited forms of capture. This demo, by
Jerome
[UNKNOWN],
does head tracking using a web cam. It's using 3JS and is Free Source, so it's
something you can instantly use yourself. Motion capture can only do so much.
Systems that use markers can track only those markers. For example, hand and
finger gestures will not be caught by a full body capture system. Motion
tracking is also affected by the limitations of the actors in the world itself.
There are real world constraints on real world performances, and the data is
only as good as your actors can provide. Artists generating animation have
unlimited freedom, at least until they run out of time or money. To get back to
our humble drinking bird, the way this process could work is that we track the
motion over time. The positions tracked could be turned into the amount of
rotation of the Z-axis for the bird's moving part. We would then have a giant
table of values, which we could interpolate between. At some given time T, the
angle of rotation is Z. Apply this rotation at that time, and we have an
animation matching real life.